- Jesus savait que la maladie
rodait à Madrid. Il s'était
infoé é sur les réseaux sociaux
pour connaître les symptômes de
la variole simienne : la fièvre,
les pustules sur le corps.
Il y prêtait attention.
Il se croyait en sécurité quand
il a rencontré un jeune homme
avec qui il a une relation
sesexuelle.
Il doutait encore. Puis trois
petites lésions sont apparues
sur son corps.
Pour freiner la propagation
de la variole simienne,
l'Espagne a lancé une campagne
de vaccination pour les
populations les plus à risque
il y a deux semaines. Le pays
a acheté 12 000 doses de vaccin
contre la variole, mais n'a pu
en recoioir que 5000 jusqu'ici.
Les rendez-vs s sont difficiles
à obtenir, mais les volontaires,
eux, sont de plus en plus
nombreux. Jaimin n'a pas rendez-
vous, mais il espère obtenir
l'une des 90 doses qui seront
distribuées aujourd'hui.
Malgré ses efforts de prévention
timides diront certains,
l'Espagne compteujujourd'hui
plus de 4500 cas répertoriés
de la maladie, ce qui en fait
le pays d'Europe le plus touché.
Et la variole simienne continue
de se propager rapidement
partout sur la planète, ce qui a
poussé l'organisation mondiale
de la santé, fin juillet,
à décréter une urgee e sanitaire
publique de portée
internationale, son plus haut
niveau d'alerte. La dernèère
fois que l'OMS avait lancée
une telle alerte, c'était
en 2020, pour la COVID.
À l'échelle mondiale, l'OMS
compte maintenant 27 000 cas
de variole simienne.
Louis déplore l'absence
de communication claire
des autorités de son pays.
Il a trouvé ça les informations
pour la vaccination sur des
groupes de partages et non sur
les sites officiels de la santé
publique. Il croit que c'est
parce que la majorité des cas
touche des hommes qui ont
des rapports sexuels avec
des hommes.
Un relent d'homophobie croit
cette militante des droits
LGBTQ+ qui risque d'exacerber
une crise de santé publique.
Il faut dire plus clairement
que tout le monde est à risque
croit-elle.
Plus que la douleur, c'est
l'isolement que Jesus a trouvé
difficile avec la maladie.
La peur et la honte, Jesus tente
de les surmonter pour prévenir,
dit-il. Les virus ne font pas
de discrimination.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
adadio-Canada, Madri